bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce 7 8 l'actu
du Mercredi 16 avril nous débutons avec
une page politique Christine Boutin
conseillère générale des Yvelines
ancienne présidente du Parti chrétien
démocrate se lance dans la campagne aux
européennes elle a présenté ce mercredi
matin ses orientations un changement de
civilisation c'est ce que souhaite
mettre en place Christine Boutin et son
nouveau mouvement force vie se décrivant
comme une Européenne convaincue elle
propose de remettre l'humain au centre
de la société dans son programme on
retrouve la défense de l'embryon la
reprise en main politique de la Banque
centrale européenne ou encore
l'instauration d'un revenu de base entre
450 et 500 euros par adulte force vie se
veut un label au-dessus des
appartenances politiques et religieuses
comme l'explique Christine Boutin au
micro de Claire Cambier
si la France réaffirme que la personne
humaine et l'alpha et l'oméga de toute
décision politique je peux vous dire que
les choses changeront mais de toute
façon c'est une étape culturellement les
choses sont en train de se faire nous
sommes certainement des précurseurs et
nous allons bien voir nous donnons aux
Français une option politique différente
de tout ce qu'on leur offre aujourd'hui
je suis bien placé par expérience pour
bien connaître de l'intérieur la vie
politique française et je vous dis que
ce soit l'UMP que ce soit le PS ou que
ce soit le Front national ils sont tous
dans le même système ils sont tous dans
cette réalité où la personne humaine
devient seconde nous ce que nous voulons
c'est réhabiliter l'homme notre priorité
elle est là et nous irons jusqu'au bout
et ça ira plus loin que les Européennes
de toute façon quel que soit notre
résultat nous disons en français nous
vous proposons une autre offre politique
on poursuit ça cette suite l'actu avec
l'invité du soir Bernard Delattre
bonsoir vous êtes journaliste localiste
c'est comme ça que vous vous définissez
vous êtes auteur d'un livre dans les
coulisses de la presse locale livre qui
va paraître à la fin du mois d'avril il
faut dire pour ce peut-être qui vous
connaissent et qui regarde TV film vous
avez le vrai pendant 36 ans en presse
locale donc 32 ans aux nouvelles des
Yvelines Val de Versailles les nouvelles
de Rambouillet et vous avez d'ailleurs
été chef d'agence ici à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines entre 84 et
2000 alors dans ce livre vous racontez
quoi vos années de presse locale oui
c'est ça j'ai voulu que ça soit
témoignage témoigner un peu parce que
moi moi je viens de Saône-et-Loire
j'étais dans un petit village de
Saône-et-Loire à côté de Gueugnon
célèbre pour son football et moi j'ai
toujours rêvé d'être journalistes et
j'étais interne au lycée Bonaparte à
Autun la sixième à la terminale puis moi
c'est j'ai toujours voulu être
journaliste et j'avais on avait créé en
66 66 68 un petit journal du lycée qui
s'appelait La Cloche libertin c'est une
clause qui sonnait toutes les deux et à
partir de
sur les journalistes c'était un monde un
peu secret
j'ai essayé de faire un bouquin que
j'aurais aimé lire quand j'étais jeune
quoi expliquer un peu les coulisses
comment ça se passe comment
d'abord pourquoi la presse locale
pourquoi est-ce que je connais le mieux
quoi j'ai travaillé 32 ans 36 ans et
puis donc actuellement il y a beaucoup
de on parle beaucoup de tout va mal
c'est la photo média vous avez
Jean-François Kahn qui a fait un livre
leur art médiatique vous avez le gars de
Mediapart et de vie pleinel aussi qui
qui a fait un livre dire non les médias
sont un peu dans le collimateur
justement on parle beaucoup de la
prestationale et la presse locale est
importante aussi
la presse locale elle souffre moins que
la prestationale la prestationale
souffre énormément il y avait 30 titres
en 1945 il en reste 6 il en reste que 6
il reste que 6 journaux nationaux et le
gars au niveau de
un message qui est délivré ce qui est à
votre avis les différents de ce que peut
délivrer évidemment des journalistes de
presse nationale la presto calme elle
tient mieux parce que la proximité il y
a beaucoup Ouest-France c'est 27 agences
et le tient mieux mais ça commence à
descendre ça y est on est arrivé un peu
il faut qu'il y ait une réflexion aussi
sur la presse locale donc avec les
municipales elle est un peu remontée
mais après faudra tenir il faut il faut
une réflexion c'est quoi comme réflexion
les choix éditoriaux parce que donc
quand la presse locale régionale a perdu
des lecteurs je pense qu'à un moment il
y a peut-être eu des excès derrière on a
voulu faire dans dans le fait divers à
fond et puis je pense qu'il faut
peut-être prendre du recul maintenant
moi j'ai le recul et voir gueule pas
tout accès sur les faits divers combien
de fois on m'a dit coco là tu fais la
une sur le fait divers quoi c'est ça
dans ce livre alors vous racontez
effectivement c'est c'est 36 années vous
me parlez notamment dans votre groupe de
presse des nombreux rachats que vous
avez connu il y a eu cinq rachats il y a
eu en 20 ans il y a eu deux plans
sociaux et on juste là de la douleur que
ça peut représenter pour les équipes
vous parlez aussi de vos rencontres
la chance de côtoyer des gens
fantastiques dans les années 80 en ville
nouvelle il y a eu Jean gemmane et
Christine Coudin blackburger
j'ai vu les débuts j'ai vu les débuts de
Jamel Debbouze je crois que j'ai fait sa
première interview écrite à l'époque il
faisait la première partie de Bouge là
des il y a aussi des gens dont on parle
moins moi je me rappelle bien c'est
Rachid Benzin par exemple de Trappes que
d'ici marocaine qui avait fondé issu de
secours et qui faisait faire du du du du
combat des des arts martiaux tous les
jeunes de banlieue il a récupéré plein
de jeunes il a fait venir soigner il a
fait activer pour le le dialogue
musulman chrétien il a fait plein de
choses il a fait venir sur Emmanuel à
trappe c'était j'ai envie de raconter
tout ça aussi ça sera peut-être un autre
livre et aussi des même dans la presse
il y a des gens
j'ai débuté avec Michel legier là
il est maire de Montigny actuellement
mais il a d'abord été journaliste aux
nouvelles tout à fait
avec lui à l'époque on était plus
nombreux on avait le temps de jouer au
foot je peux dire
je peux dire aux gens que moi on a connu
le foot de l'époque de d'Albert Camus
quoi qui disait que le football c'est le
ce qui permet de connaître les autres
mais je peux dire que moi j'ai connu
Michel logique comme footballeur il
était stoppeur au libéraux il était bon
ah ouais non mais c'était rassurant à
l'arrière il assure bien il savait faire
la relance c'était un bon équipier et
puis très très marrant quoi il y a le
sens de la blague sans être méchant le
fait justement d'avoir alors on va
prendre l'exemple de Michel Auger donc
vous l'avez connu en tant que
journaliste quand vous le voyez devenir
homme politique ça veut dire quoi il y a
le lien entre journaliste en politique
et très fort
l'origine médias ça veut dire quoi pour
moi un média c'est
l'interface ce qui fait le lien entre le
politique et le peuple donc voilà il est
à fond dedans on travaille beaucoup avec
les politique on nous le reproche mais
moi tous les jours ce que je connais ils
évitent la connivence on essaye de
rester objectif moi j'ai jamais eu de
cartes à aucun parti j'ai essayé de
garder toujours ma liberté j'ai aussi
bien travaillé avec des mères
communistes comme Bernard Hugo attrapent
à une époque des mères UMP comme Gérard
Larcher à Rambouillet voilà on essaye
toujours d'être objectif comme vous le
faites donner la parole aux alentours je
vais vous sur votre plateau des cas
quelqu'un de droite il y a quelqu'un de
gauche et viseur
ce qui se fait toujours c'est la base du
métier qu'on vous dites mais il faut pas
l'oublier c'est vraiment les
fondamentaux et déjà en 1848 Victor Hugo
intervenait à Assemblée nationale pour
défendre la liberté de la presse si
jamais acquis
donc auteur je l'ai dit dans les
coulisses de la presse locale vous
animez aussi vous allez aussi animer un
débat le 26 avril à Rambouillet la
presse écrite une valeur républicaine à
préserver
moi quand je vois François
qui a disparu alors que dans les années
50-60 ça tirait en train un million et 2
millions d'exemplaires il y avait des
signatures comme Blaise Cendra arc et
celles des géants de la littérature
maintenant il y a plus rien quoi ça me
fait mal au cœur et le prochain qui
apparemment risque de disparaître c'est
Libé quoi quelque part même si on
partage pas les idées de l'idée ça
appartient au patrimoine il faut que
chaque comme disait Victor Hugo la
minorité d'aujourd'hui peut être la
majorité de demain et ça vise versa en
le donc il faut que la minorité est un
moyen d'expression la presse écrite
reste un fantastique moyen d'expression
il faut que ça reste le jour où il y
aura plus que un ou deux jours
quotidiens nationaux les gens pleurant
une ouverture avec Mathieu Pigasse mais
c'est à suivre en tout cas Bernard de
Lattes donc défenseur de la presse
écrite on a bien compris merci beaucoup
d'être venu sur le plateau du 7 8 l'actu
donc l'auteur d'un livre apparaître à la
fin avril dans les coulisses de la
presse locale et puis si on veut vous
rencontrer vous serez samedi 26 avril à
la médiathèque de Rambouillet pour une
conférence des bases sur la défense
justement de cette presse écrite et vous
lisez toujours les nouvelles oui bien
sûr je suis abonné et puis j'achète je
regarde la télé nationale je regarde
votre télé je suis un boulimique de
l'info je regarde j'achète des magazines
de gauche et de droite j'achète des
quotidien merci beaucoup
on part direct direction Élancourt il y
a 150 ans on essaie la Croix-Rouge un
anniversaire que n'aurait pas manqué la
section locale de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines une exposition
se tient justement jusqu'à vendredi à
l'hôtel de Villedieu en cours
l'histoire de la Croix-Rouge est née il
y a 150 ans avec Henri Dunant sur les
champs de la bataille de Solférino
découvrant l'ampleur du désastre humain
il lance les fondements de ce qui allait
devenir la structure internationale tel
qu'on la connaît aujourd'hui il réagit
d'abord pour s'occuper de ses blessés
qui ensuite est créé un livre sur les
qui s'appelle souvenirs de Solférino et
qui finalement parvient avec les données
Napoléon III d'ailleurs à réunir les
premières conventions de Genève qui ont
été les premières fois où des États ont
accepté de se dire bon on va souvent en
tête se faire la guerre mais si on se
fait la guerre on va au moins respecter
un certain nombre de règles comme ne pas
ne plus bombarder les les ambulances ou
les hôpitaux je pense que les gens font
pas forcément le rapprochement entre les
Conventions de Genève qui sont pourtant
tout organisées par la Croix-Rouge et et
la Croix-Rouge alors le fait que ce soit
à Genève tous les deux bon le fait que
le drapeau de la Croix-Rouge c'est le
négatif du drapeau suisse ne marque pas
forcément les esprits et pourtant la
Croix-Rouge aujourd'hui ce sont 90
millions de volontaires dans le monde
l'antenne 50 chinoise compte 120
bénévoles en 2013 les bénévoles
cinquantinois ont proposé quelques 27000
heures de bénévolat c'est de l'aide
alimentaire au travers des épiceries
sociales c'est de vestimentaire c'est de
l'accueil pour aider les gens qui ont
des difficultés c'est fournir une
adresse aux gens qui n'en n'ont pas
c'est
remplir les documents des gens qui
savent pas les remplir c'est avoir une
halte répit pour malade d'Alzheimer
l'antenne 50 chinoise recherche toujours
des bénévoles si vous voulez en savoir
plus rendez-vous cette semaine en mairie
d'Élancourt l'exposition est itinérante
elle partira ensuite à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux
et si votre sœur ou votre mère devenait
les héroïnes d'un film d'animation c'est
ce qui a été proposé à l'occasion d'un
atelier justement sur le film
d'animation à Guyancourt
concentration minutie il faut de la
patience pour réaliser un film
d'animation l'artiste Julie Dumont l'a
expliqué au curieux venu donner vie aux
héroïnes de leur quotidien elle s'anime
grâce aux nouveaux outils technologiques
vu que là c'est en comité réduit j'ai
essayé de montrer un peu un maximum de
choses qui existent aujourd'hui et il y
en a de plus en plus là en l'occurrence
et le plus simple le la technique du
stop motion image par image avec un
appareil photo avec l'exposition héroïne
la femme est à l'honneur pour ce petit
atelier ce sont-elles les têtes
d'affiche un hommage important pour
Brigitte qui découvre l'animation
aujourd'hui c'est l'histoire de ma
grand-mère qui était une sacrée belle
femme et aussi une sacrée grand-mère
donc c'est ce que j'essaye de mettre en
image de façon un petit peu drôle voilà
avec un fond neutre un appareil photo et
quelques idées il est possible de
réaliser son petit film d'animation pour
Brigitte il est surtout question de
souvenir et de transmission
à ma mère encore mère est décédée donc
je pourrai pas lui montrer ça permet
voilà de concrétiser des choses de
l'histoire familiale les apprentis
réalisateurs sont repartis avec un petit
film d'une dizaine de secondes de quoi
s'amuser en famille
allez cette information culture pour
continuer Richard Bohringer devait être
sur la scène du prismaël en cours mardi
29 avril en raison des ennuis de santé
du comédien la production a décidé
d'annuler tous les spectacles de sa
tournée le spectacle d'Élancourt et donc
également annulé la direction du prisme
nous a fait savoir qu'elle était dans
l'attente d'information de la part de la
production pour éventuellement repousser
la date du spectacle en septembre ou en
octobre les spectateurs qui ont déjà
acheté leur billet seront bien entendu
tenu au courant
deuxième volet de notre série consacrée
au motards de la police nationale
aujourd'hui Anthony Reich nous fait
découvrir l'émission d'une patrouille
dite sérigraphié nous les retrouvons aux
abords du château de Versailles sur les
images de Jonathan villemann et un
montage de Sandrine fontaine
vous les croisez très souvent sur la
route parfois en intervention la
trentaine de motards de la police
nationale réalisent régulièrement des
patrouilles sur ces zones de compétences
sur le département avec 7,5 millions de
visiteurs en 2013 le château de
Versailles est évidemment une place très
surveillée par les policiers l'été
dernier une touriste brésilienne c'est
d'ailleurs fait renverser lors d'un
chargement devant la place d'Armes
depuis les policiers redoublent de
vigilance sur le comportement des
conducteurs d'autobus qui doivent
décharger leur passagers dans une zone
bien définie sous peine d’une amende de
135 euros un règlement très peu respecté
par les chauffeurs pourtant habituer des
lieux le guide
avait appelé pour dire on sort et voilà
est-ce que tu peux venir nous chercher
c'est ce qu'il a fait il espérait
charger là je crois que c'est 75 ou 80
euros
le stationnement intérieur donc je pense
que tu peux en faire d'économie voilà
comme il était garé là on est sûr que
c'est pour ça je l'ai contrôlé il a
reconnu les fêtes tout ça il était pas
en pleine charge en pleine décharge et
était un peu en attente j'ai invité à
aller au se stationner en 2013 un tiers
des personnes tuées sur la route était
des piétons
sur la route les brigadiers croisent
parfois des usagers prêts à tout pour ne
pas perdre leur permis cet automobiliste
se fait contrôler pour la première fois
elle ne va malheureusement pas conserver
ses 12 points
vous êtes allés en face
et ici il y a un sens interdit
ma sœur
refuse de signer ou vous signer comme
vous voulez
je peux pas mettre
je vous donne des papiers vous signez
vous signez pas mais vous décidez vous
me dites
pas le casque de moto parce que c'est le
même prix
je fais pas ça je suis désolé
vous signez pas
vous me dites
finalement cette conductrice ne signera
pas le procès-verbal et prendra donc le
risque de se faire convoquer par les
instants judiciaires pour contester ses
amendes en 2013 près de 10 000
infractions routières ont été constatées
sur les Yvelines
ce 7 8 heures actuelle est terminée
merci de votre attention tout de suite
dans quelques instants kiosque présenté
par Aurélia Debussy qui ont consacré aux
idées de sortie pour les vacances de
Pâques bonne soirée à demain